Okay, so we've looked at a number of different ways
of interacting with MongoDB collections. We've looked at, how we go
about inserting documents into the collection and a number of
different ways of querying a collection to find documents of interest.
We're now going to turn our attention to updating. And
by that, I mean making modifications to existing documents in a
collection. There are several ways to do this in MongoDB. The
one that we're going to look at here, is the use
of the save command. Now in PyMongo, this is
actually a method on collections objects. Save does one
or two things. If the object we pass to
it already has an underscore ID and a document with
that underscore ID is already in the collection. Then
it simply replaces the document with that ID with this
one. If there is no document with that underscore
ID or the object that we're passing does not have
an underscore ID field, then MongoDB will create a
new document for us. Okay, so what we're doing
here is, querying the cities collection for the city
Munich or Munchen. And in this case, we'll get
back a single document. And the reason why we're
guaranteed to get back a single document, is because
instead of using find, we're using the find_one command.
Instead of returning a cursor as find does, find_one simply
returns towards the first document it finds, that
matches our query. So what we're doing in
this code, is modifying this city document, so
that it has a field for isoCountyCode and
value for the appropriate three-character isoCountyCode for Germany,
which is DEU. Okay? When we call save
here, this document will be updated to include
this field. Let's go ahead and run this. Okay,
and now what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to check that the document was updated appropriately. Here
we can see the document before we did the
update. I did a find on it earlier. And now
we see this isoCountyCode field, showing up in the
document. So what I'm going to do here is look at
a few different examples, run them and then test
the results of having run them, in the MongoDB shell.